bonjour mais salut bonjour alors je sais
que vous êtes à montréal pour recevoir
une médaille du barreau pour votre
contribution exceptionnelle au monde la
justice je vais quand même pas vous
demander quel est votre contribution
exceptionnelle se seraient heurtés votre
votre humilité sans but mais on sait
quand on vous connaît un peu que vous
êtes animé par ce désir de transmettre
vos connaissances vous avez enseigné
vous avez été
au barreau et je me dis quand on est
juge en chef comment est-ce qu'on peut
transmettre nos connaissances là une
manière de le faire c'est justement ce
qu'on va faire à québec la semaine
prochaine c'est à dire c'est à dire
d'aller rencontrer la population
générale au musée dans l'est du québec
de rencontrer les étudiants des écoles
secondaires alors les neuf juges la cour
suprême pour la deuxième fois dans
l'histoire de la cour se rendra à
l'extérieur d'ottawa pour siéger mais
également faire d'autres activités alors
il ya l'activité de rencontre avec les
étudiants des écoles secondaires les
neuf juges dans les neuf écoles
différentes il y aura effectivement
de cause qu'on entendra à québec n'a pas
opéré justice de québec et on
rencontrera également les gens au musée
pour qu'ils nous posent des questions et
finalement le vendredi on a une
rencontre avec les étudiants en droit de
l'université laval est ce que les
professeurs donc c'est une phase alors
une façon de donner effectivement
l'information sur ce que la cour fait
sur ce que le système judiciaire général
faisait bon on sait aussi que vous êtes
quelqu'un de très préoccupés par l'accès
à la justice ça beaucoup de d'acception
ce mot-là l'accès à la justice on sait
que en raison des coûts c'est difficile
d'y accéder comment ont pu lier remédier
à part fournir un avocat tout le monde
n'y a pas de solution magique première
des choses mais effectivement l'accès à
la justice est fondamental pour assurer
la société une forte démocratie il a
bien être et la liberté parce que
l'accès à juste ça veut dire beaucoup de
choses ça veut dire d'aller devant les
tribunaux pour faire valoir ses droits
dans un délai raisonnable avec des coûts
raisonnables ça veut dire également
avoir l'information sur ses droits alors
l'accès logiciels permettent aux gens de
connaître leurs droits mais également de
connaître les tribunaux connaître les
juges qu'est ce qu'ils font comment ils
font pour quoi ils le font alors c'est
un peu dans ce sens là où moi et mes
collègues depuis que je suis devenu chef
en 2017 on a décidé d'aller donner le
plus d'informations possible aux gens de
démystifier non seulement la cour
suprême également les tribunaux en
général avec plusieurs initiatives
telles que par exemple la cause en bref
d'un contrat bref c'est sur une page on
résume en termes clairs et accessibles
l'essentiel d'une décision que l'on veut
rendre qui peut en prendre 40
pour dire aux gens quel est l'impact de
ces décisions là sur vos droits sur ceux
de votre famille vos amis il ya la revue
annuelle qu'on fait maintenant depuis
depuis que je suis devenu juge en chef
ou où on indique qu elles sont été les
activités de la course durant la
dernière année les arts efforts et les
principales activités la conférence de
presse ceci est une conférence de presse
quand même pas banal ça juge en chef qui
fait une conférence de presse à tous les
ans web est un petit pot de lassus à
l'époque mais
maintenant la quatrième conférence de
presse et ça donne l'occasion pour moi
de donner un peu l'état des lieux à la
population canadienne québécoise et
canadienne sur les activités de la cour
quels sont les principaux défis qu
est-ce qu on peut s'attendre comme défi
également d'avenir c'est dans cet esprit
de de transparence de donner
l'information pour pour permettre au
jade apprécie également c'est dur
d'apprécier quelque chose qu'on connaît
pas en effet alors
puis c'est pas tout le monde qui a accès
à l'information pour bien connaître ce
que veut dire un système de justice et
on sait que vous avez ce souci-là de
rendre la justice compréhensible c'est
pas donné à tout le monde d'être limpide
même si les juges se forcent assurément
mais acquis servier se doit d'être
compréhensible c'est le rôle de qui de
rendre la justice facile à comprendre je
pensais le rose de tous les acteurs l'un
d'eux mêmes
et ça inclut les juges alors je pense
que les juges de plus en plus sont
sensibles à l'opportunité de rendre leur
décision accessible le plus accessible
possible à tous dans un langage
accessible par exemple mais c'est
également la responsabilité de faire
connaître leur travail
et donc vous savez à la cour suprême par
exemple on a maintenant un compte
twitter on est content est agréé
ce soit vous qu'il est qu'il arrive pas
encore
mais disons qu'on utilise tous les
moyens possibles des évidemment le
système de justice les cours au canada
ont des moyens limités
et c'est la même chose dans tous les
pays où la règle de droit prévaut de
toutes les démocraties
l'argent n'a pas été nécessairement
consacré au système de
la santé l éducation c'est bien comme ça
tant mieux oui mais ça les rejoindre ils
demandent tous les inconvénients que
nous subissons maintenant en termes de
délais en termes de coût en termes de
sous financement
vous avez souligné je vous entendu
plusieurs fois à mon grand bonheur
souligné l'importance du rôle des médias
évidemment je prenne un peu pour ma
paroisse mais en quoi comment on peut
définir je voudrais que vous précisiez
le rôle fondamental que vous estimez que
les médias jouent dans ce dans cette
espèce de dynamique qu'on partage
littéralement pour faire comprendre la
justice un rôle fondamental c'est vous
qui l'utilisent et puis je suis
entièrement d'accord alors avoir des
médias indépendants
forme c'est essentiel pour une
démocratie comme c'est essentiel d'avoir
une magistrature indépendante forte
également et au fil des ans on s'est
rendu compte que les médias
traditionnels
ont le moins de place oui la cause de
toutes sortes de raisons le financement
difficile de compétition et caetera et
donc les tribunaux souvent se fiait
autres médias traditionnels pour
transmettre l'information au public
informer les publics sur les décisions
rendues par les tribunaux sur les juges
eux-mêmes et le terrain et là c'est plus
difficile alors les médias sociaux ont
pris un peu comme la relève mais les
médias sociaux même si on a des
décomptes de médias sociaux à la cour
ils sont pas soumis aux mêmes règles de
déontologie que les médias traditionnels
et s'adonner à l'occasion des dérapages
la mémé informations de la mauvaise
information et ça c'est dommageable
c'est la raison pour laquelle on aide
les médias traditionnels la continuer
leur travail mais il est important c'est
que ces gens là comme vous
demeure bien présent dans l'activité
sociale d'ailleurs on le voit vous
imprimez vraiment un style ans à la cour
suprême vous avez de l'ouverture vous
prêchez pour la proximité avec le public
c'est formidable il ya des experts il ya
des justes qui disent que ça aide à
lutter contre la désinformation
comment on commet sa lutte contre la
désinformation d'être proche du monde ça
nous permet de donner la bonne
information alors comme je le disais un
peu plus tôt c'est difficile d'apprécier
quelque chose qu'on ne connaît pas alors
il faut donc permettre de
donner à la population la bonne
information et c'est en ayant des
activités comme effectivement siéger à
l'extérieur d'ottawa qu'on peut
atteindre ces objectifs là au moins en
partie il ya des gens a contrario qui
disent que c'est pas une bonne idée de
se rapprocher du monde comme si on
s'exposait un peu trop assoit la
critique ou à la familiarité peut-être
c'est toujours un juste équilibre on
n'est pas les juges ne doivent pas faire
partie du débat public on doit pas
s'immiscer dans le débat public on doit
pas s'immiscer dans les commentaires sur
les politiques gouvernementales ou autre
ça c'est les élus qui s'occupe de ça
c'est les gens les gens d'affaires les
élus les juges ont une obligation de
réserve mais ça veut pas dire pour
autant qu'on doit pas prendre des
opportunités pour expliquer notre home
comment fonctionne qui sommes nous
comment on a été nommé comment une
décision est rendue comment se fait-il
que telle décision a été entendu par la
cour suprême ou non ou un autre tribunal
alors je pense que ça fait partie je ne
pense pas que la transparence le dire
familiarité mais s'il ya des gens je
pense qu'ils confondent puisque vous
êtes plus proche puisque vous faites des
conférences de presse il ya des gens qui
s'attendent à ce qu'on puisse vous
griller un peu et que vous répondiez à
des questions un peu plus corsé y est
alors ils ont tort ils seront déçus et
ce produit forcément vous dire ici que
la cour suprême un plan de communication
je me demande si le message son rang et
surtout si ça se mesure comment on fait
pour mesurer
c'est une bonne question je pense que ce
sont toujours des efforts
qui sont en continu à d'autres mots je
ne pense pas qu'on va arriver à une
certaine période on va dit bon voilà
alors sur nos statistiques dont on est
rendu à tel niveau on arrête toute
initiative je pense que on ne possède
pas cette philosophie là à chaque année
on temps de trouver des manières de
l'encore de l'avant avec cette
philosophie de transparence
de permettre à la population d'avoir
plus d'information on n'est pas tenu par
des barèmes comme tel pour mesurer comme
tel le succès
sur mac ça existe
par exemple aussi dans les faits que
notre initiative de cause en bref on
était très très grand succès aussi parce
que les gens nous disent c'est utiliser
ça devait être utilisée à l'origine par
le public en général qui n'avaient pas
les servants de formation juridique on
s'aperçoit maintenant que ces résumés de
force utilisée par les médias
d'information par les professeurs de
droit par les avocats up et par les jeux
alors donc je pense que c'est un succès
mais comme barème de référence où
voyez-vous winnipeg en 2019 quand on a
tenté la première fois de se déplacer à
l'extérieur d'ottawa et bien les gens
étaient en ligne à 6h30 le matin pour
avoir une chance d'entrer dans la salle
de cours pour moi ça parle de soi
c'était donc la réponse des crs de
besoin et puis on veut on veut combler
ça quand le public voit c'est le juge
des grands titres et là je pense à un en
particulier que j'ai vu récemment le
québec où le gouvernement du québec en
cours contre contre qui se dispute
devant les tribunaux avec la cour du
québec je me dis mon dieu quel message
sans voix
on a un peu raison d'être cynique quand
on voit le gouvernement se chicaner avec
la côte du québec non mais pour les
mêmes raisons que je vous ai annoncé
tantôt mon obligation de rêveur je ne
prononcerai pas sur ce dossier là parce
qu'il risque peut-être de venir devant
nous à la cour suprême qui sait comme
l'autre sur lequel je ne vous posez
aucune question qui me brûlait les
lèvres
alors vous êtes une excellente
journaliste et un tank excellente
journaliste surprend pas que vous
vouliez la poser mais en tant que
journaliste vous savez également que je
peux pas y penser ça et en tant que
salon juge en chef vous allez regarder
demeurant baril
évidemment vous n'êtes pas aveugle ni
enfermée dans une tour d'ivoire ce qu'on
a tant reproché aux juges dans l'ancien
temps est là depuis des mois on voit
cette espèce de mouvement qui attaquent
les élites qui attaquent les élus les
médias le système judiciaire on a vu à
tahoua de vue partout on a vu madame
trilane se faire harceler par un espèce
de taupins on voit des événements comme
ça depuis des mois et on se demande
qu'est ce que les juges peuvent y faire
un pot vous personnellement mais qu'est
ce que le système peut y faire ou les
juges c'est très dommage évidemment on
le voit on constate un certain dérapage
qui est cause est probablement partie
par la désinformation
et c'est dangereux parce que ça peut de
façon insidieuse miner le système la
démocratie et nos libertés qu'est-ce
qu'on peut faire on peut compter sur les
médias est dépendant de dénoncer ces
attitudes là on peut penser également
aux bars aux associations
professionnelles comme ils l'ont fait
d'ailleurs récemment je sais qu'il ya eu
des lettres ouvertes qui ont été
déposées pour dénoncer ça il appartient
aux élus aussi le calmer le jeu puis
deux puis de dénoncer ces actes alors je
pense qu'il ya pas de remède ultime je
pense que c'est ça appartient à tout le
monde de s'assurer que ces dérapages
l'eau ne se produise plus est ce que les
juges auront besoin de sécurité à un
certain point
peut-être ne sais pas moi de
prononcer là-dessus là on est chanceux
quand même au canada au québec de vivre
dans un environnement car l'intérêt
secure avec une forte démocratie qu une
magistrature que j'estime la plus
impartiale et indépendante au monde
savait que on exporte notre expertise
scolarisés là on était d'ailleurs en
ukraine juste avant la guerre il ya
quelques mois on a formé les juges
là-bas pendant dix ans donnait des cours
sur les principes d'éthique la
déontologie on le fait avec d'autres
pays également donc on est quand même
chanceux d'avoir cette institution là
une magistrature indépendante impartiale
et donc il appartient à tous de
s'assurer que sa demeure comme ça en la
respectant oui parce que souvent je vous
entends où je lis des reportages à
partir de vos entrevue où vous dites la
démocratie peut être ébranlée où il faut
être aux aguets ça veut dire quoi être
aux aguets qu'est-ce qu'on fait une fois
qu'on a
repéré quelque chose il faut le dénoncer
à l'autre mouche pense la pire erreur
c'est de ne rien faire parce que façon
insidieux il peut y avoir d impact à
moyen et long termes négatifs sur sur la
crédibilité de ces institutions là et
c'est important de d'assurer les gens et
de d'assurés qui compte qu'il confirme
qu'il continue d'avoir foi dans leurs
institutions l'assemblée nationale
parlement les grandes institutions mais
également la magistrature les tribunaux
et parce qu à moyen long terme et peut
avoir un impact notre démocratie liberté
il faut traiter ça je vous écoute et
j'entends il faut traiter somme un titre
que la violence personnelle entre deux
personnes il faut dénoncer sur se
produire on regarde quelqu'un d'autre en
occuper tous les gens qui ont un intérêt
qui peuvent le faire doivent le faire
tout ce qu'on doit évidemment on peut
pas comparer la cour suprême du canada à
celle des états unis là c'est inévitable
on le fait forcément parce qu'on est si
proche parce qu'on connaît la cause
prime des états unis on connaît mal à
notre jeu
je sais pas qui dans la rue pourrait
nommer trois juges de la cour suprême
alors qu'aux états unis on dirait que
tout le monde connaît la cour suprême et
mais elle est extrêmement différente de
la nôtre ali très divisée elle est très
polarisée qu'est ce qui fait que on se
distingue et qu'on arrivera pas là nous
j'espère qu'on arrivera jamais là et je
pense qu'on n'y arrivera pas parce qu'on
a deux sociétés complètement différentes
sociétés américaines est tellement
polarisé ça se reflète dans la
composition de leurs institutions et
notamment la cour suprême alors demain
je veux pas créer de
d'incident diplomatique
parce que on se parle pions on se reçoit
habituellement c'est une tradition
dentelée cour suprême mais
je suis bien heureux moi d'être en chef
de la course comme ce qu'a dit non pas
d'une autre cour suprême et je pense que
quand en gardant justement la
transparence en s'assurant de la
nomination transparente des juges
non politique dans des comités des
parades à savoir aider à continuer à
voir démocratie pinottes notre
impartialité et indépendance judiciaire
justement vous abordé le sujet en
parlant de nomination on peut pas passer
à côté de la nomination de madame
o'bomsawin vous accueillez une première
juge autochtone dans vos rangs est ce
que vous vous dites mon dieu il était
grand temps et qu'est-ce qu'on a dont
été privé de son expertise jusqu'à
maintenant
écoutez moi ça fait des années que je
dis ça remonte aux années où j'étais
retenu montréal 2001 2002 où je dis que
les gens les citoyens doivent se
reconnaître dans leur institution les
grandes institutions et que ce soit
l'assemblée nationale le gouvernement ou
les cours les tribunaux la course perd
et donc c'est essentiel pour assurer la
crédibilité des institutions et
maintenir la et et maintenir évidemment
de
le support de l'appui de la population
alors la nomination de madame le jeu
conserver des prix très bas on est très
heureux parce que justement ça s'inscrit
dans ce courant da qui fait en sorte qui
veut que les gens se reconnaissent dans
leur institution dont la cour suprême
l'année dernière le premier ministre a
nommé le juge kamal le premier juge
racisées à la cour c'est encore une fois
dans cet esprit là qu'on a bien reçu la
nomination parce que savoir permettre
une meilleure crédibilité de
l'institution est ce que vous diriez que
maintenant la cour suprême est davantage
le reflet de la société est ce que c'est
ça qu'on doit viser évidemment nous
sommes que neuf
il ya des limites à ce qu à ce qu'on
peut faire mais je pense que c'est un
message très clair et un message
important de transparence et qui va
permettre aux gens de continuer à avoir
confiance dans leur édition et et je
pense que c'est juste positif alors
qu'est-ce qui manqueraient à la cour
suprême par examen vous dit on et que
neuf l'on peut pas on peut pas
multiplier le nombre de juges mais
qu'est ce qui la rendrait encore
davantage pas cohérente mais oui
cohérente avec la société moderne
d'aujourd'hui
pour écouter ce tête avoue que je leur
ai posé la question
bon je trouve très bien telle qu'elle
est
cela dit
on n'arrête jamais de passer aux moyens
d'améliorer notre fonctionnement et vous
savez on a présentement on a trois juges
du québec de par le web soit c'est
fondamental ça va toujours rester parce
que ça fait partie maintenant de la
constitution c'est important de garder
cet aspect là de la course par le droit
civil qui vient du québec on a
maintenant des juges et racisées des
juges qui viennent de la communauté
autochtone alors moi je pense qu'on on
ne fait on ne fait de beaucoup de chemin
et moi je suis très optimiste pour
l'avenir qui ont regardé tous les ont
regardés tous les moyens d'améliorer
notre fonctionnement pour assurer que
les citoyens canadiens connaissent mieux
leur système de justice et notamment la
cour suprême et ça fait du bien
d'entendre de juge en chef dire je suis
très optimiste sans que ça me rassure
oui il faut être optimiste sinon on
l'arrêterait travailler et trouver de
nouvelles solutions mais on est quand
même il faut quand même revenir à la
base et reconnaître qu'il y a des
difficultés il y a des carences mon avis
on en vit quand même dans une société
quand même privilégié avec des
institutions fortes il ya des
soubresauts mais vous pensez pas qu'ils
vont ébranler l'institution au point de
la faire mais aussi il faut travailler
pour faux pas il faut pas prendre vaut
rien prendre pour acquis tenir pour
acquis il faut travailler quand on voit
des situations comme on a vu peut-être
l'année dernière atawad qui risque de
mettre à mal la règle de droit l'état de
droit et les libertés des gens mais il
faut dénoncer puis il faut corriger ça
mais on regarde car mais avec de fortes
institutions une
magistrature il n'a pas très bien formés
indépendante alors on continue à
travailler là dessus et bien je vous
remercie infiniment je sais que je dois
vous laisser filer monsieur wagner merci
beaucoup d'être passé dans nos studios
m'ont fait plaisir merci